[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um i want to introduce first of all the
colloquium for those who don't know or
who are attending for the first time
it's a weekly event hosted at cms as
part of the grad program
that's why we see our dear graduate
students here today and i just want to
plug next week's colloquium is going to
be a talk about non-binary binaries and
unreal meta-humans by eric friedman who
is a professor at columbia college
chicago
today's speaker is samantha shepard who
is an associate professor of cinema and
media studies in the department of
performing and media arts at cornell
university
she is the author of
sporting blackness race embodiment and
critical muscle memory on screen and
co-editor of from medea to media mogul
theorizing tyler perry
and sporting realities critical readings
on the sports documentary
professor shepard has published on film
and media and academic and popular
venues such as film quarterly the
atlantic flash art international and los
angeles review of books and she was
named a 2021 academy film scholar by the
academy of motion picture arts and
science
in today's talk professor shepard
examines how lin knowledge nottage's
satirical play by the way meet vera
stark and the paratexts
produce a speculative fiction
that
and archive about black women's media
histories staging what she calls a
phantom cinema an amalgam of real and
imagined film histories that haunt
trouble and work with and against cinema
histories to creatively illuminate
archival gaps and visual culture and the
public imagination
usually our talks go about 50 minutes
and then we'll have about 30 minutes for
q a so i will see you for q a and now i
pass the mic to professor shepard
thank you so much i really appreciate
that generous um
introduction as well as this very kind
invitation to join you all virtually
it's
wonderful to be with you while also
being separate from you um and also to
speak here at a part of this great
colloquium series and i wanted to say
thank you even though she's not able to
be here to heather hendershot for
the very generous
invitation in the beginning to join you
all today
i am going to powerpoint the hell out of
this talk so um
be ready for some visuals
um so one second as we do that awkward
thing where i say don't remember how to
share his grace i'm on sabbatical um so
i got real sabbatical energy here um
how how do i let me let me i really
should probably just double check the
energy before we started
um share screen yeah
with
all panelists
yes
okay
okay
let's go to slideshow
okay
okay
so here we go
my talk today is derived from a new book
project called a black hole
phantom cinemas and the reimagining of
black women's media histories
which attempts to critically and
creatively address the narrative voids
in cinema media scholarship about black
women's creative presence practices
histories traditions and discourses
there is a critical black hole in film
studies about black women and media in
general
i take heart and direction from scholar
and critic michelle wallace who suggests
that the cosmic trope of the black hole
however is useful for examining black
women's cultural production
denoting that black holes are not empty
celestial spaces or phenomena but rather
dense in accumulative spaces
and walls explicitly states quote
it is still difficult to apprehend black
feminist creativity as continuous and
as a continuous incoherent discourse
because of the failure to read the gaps
the location from which black women do
not speak as part of a whole spelled
w-h-o-l-e-n-h-o-l-e
in quote
now my work with my book a black hole
searches for black women's film and
media narratives and counter narratives
in the glare and gaps of film and
television scholarships physical and
digital archives and screen and stage
performances and so my talk today is as
you can see
changing the subject lynn nottage is by
the way meet vera stark in the making of
black women's film history
lynn nottage's 2011 satirical play by
the way meet bear stark stages the life
and legacy of the fictional bear stark a
black maid and struggling actress during
hollywood's golden age
knottage is a two-time pulitzer
prize-winning playwright and
screenwriter who was inspired in part by
the career of african-american actress
singer and dancer teresa harris
labeled the maid of hollywood on a 1952
cover of jet magazine
harris shared the screen alongside white
leading ladies such as barbara sanwick
marlon dietrich ginger rogers gene
harlow and bet davis in dozens of
credited and uncredited roles from the
1930s through the 1950s
a tale of black women's cinematic
representation and social erasure by the
way meet vera stark examines racism in
the film industry and contemplates the
concerns of black actresses like harris
as well as others like having mcdaniel
butterfly mcqueen and louise beavers
those who were cast in stereotypical
servant roles
in particular the play explores the
impact of the actresses professional
choices on their personal lives and
their legacies in popular culture
in her research on harris knowledge
observed quote
for a lot of black actresses the trail
ends cold they just sort of disappeared
from hollywood and you can't find out
the trail for others is that they ended
up destitute and forgotten end quote
the play's incidental title by the way
not only gestures towards these careers
and lives seen as an afterthought the
title also captures a figure of speech's
varied meanings it introduces a new
subject into a conversation signals to
events along a journey and suggest a
methodology or a process
it is in this multifaceted design that
knowledge fashions her forgotten black
actress from cinema's historical threads
weaving a patchwork persona that is as
she notes a composite of a lot of
actresses on an off-screen experiences
inspired by their circumstances and
their stories
vera's turbulent life and career are the
subject of knowledge's two-act play set
in hollywood over the course of 70 years
and imagining vera's life by the way
meet barry stark entwined fact and myth
into a recombinant historical fiction
about black actresses to borrow a phrase
from miriam petty limited and limiting
stardom in 1930s american cinema
as i will discuss with you today
knowledge's fabrication of film history
extends beyond the stage plot to also
include a digital archive documenting
their celebrity and career comprised of
websites dedicated to rediscovering vera
stark and finding vera stark
the websites are maintained by the
play's characters herb forester and
carmen levy green
now forester is described as a filmmaker
entrepreneur and musician from oakland
and levy green is characterized as a
stout and stylish academic which i can
obviously see the resemblances
um
and the author of a book on vera called
hollywood dreams
the site's digital contents include a
short documentary titled a leading lady
in a maid's uniform a closer look at the
bell of new orleans that explores vera's
first and career defining film
it also includes a trailer for a 1933
film for that 1933 film
it includes an excerpt from the
documentary lost and found refining vera
stark a robust filmography of 57 films
that starred vera and an excerpt from
her autobiography it rained on her
parade
as well as ephemera from her final
performances
and select images and fragmented
narratives about her life her
controversial career and her mysterious
disappearance in 1973 and i'll highlight
these aspects in greater detail later in
the talk
knowledge's play in peritects produce a
speculative fiction and archive about
black women's media histories staging
what i call a phantom cinema an amalgam
of real and imagined film histories that
haunt trouble and work with and against
cinema histories to creatively
illuminate archival gaps in visual
culture and the public imagination
using a film and media studies approach
to engage the transmedia play
i consider how knowledge narrates film
history and materializes archival
absences in order to make meaning of and
with black women stunted stardom in
hollywood
and while i consider the play's plot and
not just phantom cinema i closely attend
to her theatrical and digital fabulation
as well as the black feminists in black
film studies historiographic methods
that undergird her creative practice
in the end
i analyze the motives and the historical
consequences of notaj's extant digital
archive which is rediscovering vera
stark
which i argue does not recover nor
repair black film history through
additive inventory
but calculates losses through invention
this website come phantom cinema
manifests an archival apparition that
prompts consideration of lost material
and material evidence documenting major
and minor black figures subtracted from
american cinema history and our popular
memory
also these speculative digital artifacts
offer fantasmic possibilities where
black women's contribution to film haunt
both the erasure of cinema's past and
the public imagination with what could
have been and what never was
as a counter narrative and shadow
archive of black women's film history i
argue that nottage's intermediate play
and transmedia paratext are a black
feminist film origination
an intervention that in terry simone
francis terms quote is responsive to the
idea of black women as both consumers
and producers of cultural text
and at the center of this fastidious
film history is the figure of bear stark
a creative commodity bears extensive
multimedia and intertextual star images
given elusive form through the place
casting obviously but also the website's
visual paratex
and so i want to put this character's
intervention in conversation with a
positive media text specifically cheryl
denier and zoe leonard's documentation
the fictional film the fictional faith
or faye richards in the watermelon woman
from 1996 as well as the faye richards
photo archive that was created alongside
as well as turner classic movie short
video teresa harris a forgotten
overlooked star from 2020.
in doing so i want to suggest that not
just play in peritects foreground the
specific textual archival and
speculative strategies for historicizing
and reimagining black women's presence
and absence both on and off screen
so by the way
meet vera stark and as an aside this is
and is not about theresa harris just so
you know
lynn nottage is by the way meet bear
stark premiered on may 9th 2011 at
second stage theater in new york city
with film and television star snot
lathan originating the eponymous role of
a 28 year old budding black actress
living in hollywood in 1933.
and vera works as a made for gloria
mitchell a white starlet known as
america's little sweetie pie
the audience meets both women as they
rehearse a scene from the upcoming
southern epic melodrama the bell of new
orleans
now gloria plans to audition for the
lead role of marie an octoroon stricken
with scarlet fever
who falls in love with a white merchant
whom she must burn in order to protect
him from the truth of her racial
identity obviously
after reading the script for the film
vera covets the part of the enslaved
character tilly a minor but meaningful
role that she desperately wants because
the film includes slaves with lines
honey
so by the way my fear stark is a biting
satire about film industry stereotypes
and the paradoxical nature of black
celebrity that also includes varus two
friends and fellow aspiring black
actresses lottie mcbride a once slender
performer who made herself plus sides to
fit hollywood's mammy ideal
as well as anime simpkins a very
light-skinned black woman who
successfully tries to pass as brazilian
to get her big movie break you can see
them in the bottom screen and see the
bottom
image now just to give you a new
crash course on the entire
um
play
the first act
which lampoons hollywood's casting and
marginalization of black actresses
concludes with the farcical scene of
gloria hosting a gathering to convince
slausvik who is the chief of the belle
of new orleans studios celestial
pictures to cast her in the film
vera working as a maid with lottie at
the party comically attempts to secure
the rule of tilly once the film's
director maximilian von oster arrives
and to make the plot summary a bit quick
let's jump just to the second act right
which begins with the bell of new
orleans final scene
because vera did get the role of telly
where tilly utters the equivocal last
line of the film
stay awake and together we'll face a new
day
now to give you a sense of what this
film looks like let's take a good look
at the trailer
um
[Music]
as the lights go up the audience finds
itself in 2003 hollywood at the academic
colloquium rediscovering vera stark
facilitated by filmmaker and critic herb
forester the events two black panelists
include carmen levy green a professor of
media and gender studies and a foosa
asada ajobo a journalist poet and
performer
and the didactic herb that you see in
center here moderates the floatium as
the panelists passionately debate and
wildly speculate about vera's life and
career choices in particular whether or
not she was reproducing or subverting um
painful black stereotypes in her career
defining role as tilly
the play then shifts between that
colloquium and archival footage of
vera's last television interview on the
brad donovan show in 1973 which is
reenacted center stage
the scenes from the interview detail
bear's dissatisfaction with how she
remains tethered to the controversial
slave and made character of tilly
exacerbated their estates
but it's funny i play the role of tilly
a slave woman bound to her mistress and
here
all of these years later i find myself
bound to tilly a slave woman i wish i
could shake that silly little winch out
of me
but here we are nearly 40 years later
still answering questions about that
picture
i've lived a lifetime since i made it
but tilly
to leave my shame and
my glory she birthed me into a career
perhaps i had to play her to get where i
am
i don't know
during the interview very surprised to
find out donovan's special guest is
gloria who unlike vera has had a long
and celebrated career following her role
as marie in the belle of new orleans and
their strained and clipped exchange on
the talk show underscores their
complicated professional and personal
relationship leading the quilquian
panelists to speculate whether they were
employer employee cousins or even
possibly lovers
and in the end
the panelists debate the cinematic
social and personal forces that shape
their truncated career
the staged archival footage is
continually paused as the panelists
discussed and attempt to recuperate
various career choices
and as soyuki
diggs colbert argues um quote the
scholars resist
the incursion of the television archive
and their speculation about what
happened to vera but the structure of
the play both acts and was there on
screen and the television footage
situate the production of their identity
as intimately related to film projection
end quote
and the play concludes with behind the
scenes footage from the filming of the
bell of new orleans his final scene the
stage directions describe vera as
thinking preparing questioning and the
last image is a close-up of barra's face
on the verge as someone off screen yells
sound camera action
now that plot summary which may seem a
little long-winded but
needed um is to get us to think about
the concept of phantom cinemas which can
reconstruct critique revise and create
film historical imagination and practice
[Music]
now phantom cinemas are
meta-historical and they are artistic
interpretations that can open up
conditions of possibility for engaging
black film history and criticism both in
and as cultural production
phantom cinemas screened and staged call
on and intervene in cinematic past
presence and futures that have been lost
overlooked disregarded or forgotten
they events and conjure evidence of
black women's presence even as they are
partial incomplete
and unable to be empirically verified
in so doing phantom cinemas reshape the
depictions and imaginings of black women
specifically in american popular culture
and with her play in its iterative
reproductions on stage and screen i
claim that knotted stages of phantom
cinema a meld of factual and fictional
film histories to creatively explore
black women excuse me black actresses
done to stardom and obscured legacy in
hollywood
nottage and plots black film histories
into a satire about black actresses
starring in subservient roles
popularized in the 1930s
now the play dramatizes his domestic
guys pharaoh works as a maid for gloria
and plays one opposite her in the belle
of new orleans
this double act gestures towards
hollywood's hyper stereotyping and
vera's meta experiences of a maid also
correlates the material realities of
massive black women artists in america's
jim crow era
while hattie mcdaniel famously quipped
i'd rather play a maid than be one
hollywood's most successful black movie
actress of her time had in fact also
been a maid in real life at one time
by positioning vera as a real life and
real life maid
knottage situates her cinematic fantasia
in a materialist critique of the servant
served in race labor relations
vera's dual roles like mcdaniels as
mammy are layered problem sets upon
which the contradictions and fictions of
identity categories have been written
and rewritten on screen and in american
society
there as the real and movie made
disrupts singular readings of the
iconicity of the serpent image
moreover the play's general screwball
tone captures the subversive ways that
black maids give lip meaning biting
criticism sardonic stares dismissive
demeanor or flipping wise cracks to
their white female employers on and off
screen that challenge hollywood
conventions narrative strictures and
popular memory about these archetypes as
the dutiful help
by the way meet bear stark's hollywood
simulacra not only reconstructs how
mainstream cinema marginalizes black
actresses but it also debates the
discourses surrounding their films and
cinematic performances
during the comically morastic colloquium
dedicated to vera's iconic film
her rhetorical question excuse me herb
rhetorically questions quote
why are we still talking about it
in a manner that resonates similarly
with other sentiments about
controversial classics including say
gone with the wind
as historians jacqueline stewart miriam
petty and others have demonstrated gone
with the wind is replete with racial
stereotypes and racist tropes and yet
the film is also a valuable document of
and testimony to black performance
during an era when substantial roles for
black talent were extremely rare in
hollywood films
and as petty carefully argues mcdaniel's
signature performance as mammy
and her unprecedented promotion of the
film can be read as an attempt to
reframe complicate and also refute the
character's iconographic power
knowledge's play affirms these nuanced
readings of black actresses performances
and stereotypical roles with the
characters of herb commenting that vera
is at once in the role of tilly and
commenting on it even as he can see that
the images are still problematic and
cannot be apologized away
vera and her inspired real-life black
film counterparts as petty perceptively
describes
create performances that are bounded by
the strictures of american racism yet
that resonate and signify in ways that
exceed these same boundaries
and the play's historical references and
character palpam sets intersect with its
classical hollywood era setting and
knotted his own cinephilia
for example the faux film the belle of
new orleans derives its name from renee
claire's 1941 comedy the flame of new
orleans which co-starred teresa harris
in a small role as a maid and as a maid
to marlene dietrich's character
additionally we can even read anna may
or anna maria's character
and the belle of new orleans's passing
narrative as resonating with john saul's
1934 film imitation of life and the
character of piola who was played by
african-american actress freddie
washington
along with the screwball comedic
sensibilities that knowledge appreciates
of 1930s films
by the way meet vera stark also engages
the more audacious production moment
prior to the motion picture production
code in 1934.
using the air is affordable to more
controversial topics to script the
miscegenation period picture at the
center of the play storyline
and it's to this point as i previously
intimated notaj's inspiration for the
play came from viewing alpha e green's
baby face from 1933 a pre-code film
starring barbara stanwyck as
seductressly powers a woman who used her
beauty and sexuality to gain success in
a male-dominated world
knowledge recalls being surprised by how
progressive the film was how it showed a
relationship between a black woman and a
white woman that seemed somewhat
authentic
she was struck by the friendship and
conspiratorial dynamic between lily and
the character chico played by harris
who's magnetic and strong performance
stole the show in nottage's view
knowledge in fact recounts
the first time i saw teresa harris i
immediately began asking questions who
was she what was her life like where did
she come from what were her dreams what
were her desires
when i sat down to write the play it was
to answer all those questions i had not
just about theresa harris but about a
whole generation of african-american
actresses like her
the questions knowledge posits about
harris and black women's historical
omission underscores the play's lasting
query which is what happened to vera
stark
in response to this referring
in response to this refrain the
character and colloquium facilitator
herb forester obliquely answers that
quote
history is a question constantly being
rephrased
end quote likewise the play and its
paratex are notaj's intermediate
strategy of revisiting of revisiting her
original question about harris via the
teaching
hydrate
let's take that from that okay
likewise the play and its paratex are
nottaj's intermediate strategy of
revisiting her own imaginary excuse me
her own original questions about harris
via the enigmatic vera and the
confabulation of a theatrical spectacle
in phantom cinema
herb's riddle reply as riddle
destabilizes historical authority and
fixed genealogies
history is not an answer it is a method
of seeking an approach to the lacuna
within records of black actresses
cinematic and lived histories
by rephrasing these and other
historiographic questions the who what
where when and why from a black feminist
perspective a legion of new questions
are generated
invoking harris and a whole generation
of african-american actresses like her
not just phantom cinema multiplies
historical inquiries about figures at
the margins in the footnotes and erased
from eurocentric and patriarchal film
histories thereby produce thereby
producing alternative ways to review and
engage black women's cinematic past by
way of speculation interrogation and
fabulation
and by the way meet bear stark knowledge
fabulates a black film history and
thusly transforms spectatorship into an
intermediate and trans media act of
theatrical cinematic and archival
reimagination
this process emerges from notaj's desire
to learn about teresa harris yes her
life and career but also finding scant
material evidence of her life outside of
her film roles
and so harris's on-screen image and
off-screen mystery engenders knowledge's
aesthetic reimagining of the actress
through the character of vera a proxy
for her and a host of other black
actresses whose careers and lives are
forgotten or only partially documented
in black and mainstream press creative
nonfiction meaning memoirs biographies
autobiographies and personal or
institutional archives
and has knowledge details
the thing that always bothered me is
that you'd always have these very
talented african-american actresses who
would pop it up in these big roles for
two minutes literally and then disappear
knowledge further fabulates black
women's media histories writing vera
into or out of
cinema history where the fact and
possibility of her life and career
exists but has gone missing
she materializes a historical record
that is both emblematic and spectral
silhouetting the formability of a black
actress's talent and interrogating the
there but not their materiality of their
archival records or lack thereof
reimagining history and its figures from
fact and fiction knowledge draws from
the black feminist historiographical
practice of troubling what qualifies as
historical by recuperating and
reformulating black women's media
teaming black women's stories from real
histories into hypothetical visual
scenes and scenarios that can to lean on
a phrase from allison nadia field to
stand in for a usable past
the fact that not a just search for
harris was stalled by a lack of
source materials underscores the
historical consequences and motivations
of her creative process
her play is not an undoing of film
history with the morass of
misinformation
rather by the way meet vera stark
reauthorizes and sutures together
accounts memories and myths into
elliptical paths that are bleak but
telling revisions of cinema history
knowledge's creative acts can best be
understood within a broader critical
frame and histographical excuse me
histographic method specific to black
diasporic scholarship
within black feminist traditions
scholars such as tony k bambara and
paula giddings attempt their respective
deep sightings and rescue missions to
locate when and where black women enter
society discourses and the public
imagination
knowledge's cultural production enacts
this process twofold focusing on
african-american women who have been
marginalized by circumstance and who are
trying to assert their presence on and
off screen
and despite vastly different historical
and methodological stakes nonage's work
is in conversation with cydia hartman's
influential and rigorous advancement of
speculative attempts to document captive
fugitive and wayward black women's lives
via her practice of critical fabulation
hartman's writing method innovatively
attends to archival absence and violence
reading archival documents and the lack
thereof at their constitutive limits to
reimagine those african-american women's
narratives excluded from or obscured by
historical record
even as knowledge in wallace's terms
reads the gaps in film history as part
of a whole
like hartman she practices narrative
restraint and refuses to describe
unrecoverable past completely meaning
she respects black noise
particularly the noise that resists
legibility
and through the play in its paratext
vera shifts in and out of focus with
more unknown than known about the film
star because of narrative fragmentation
by the way meat bear stark contemplates
the life legacy and mystery of the
fictional or actress in a way that
resists
closure and clarity as it slips off
stage and into digital spaces sorry
digital spaces
deepening the mysteries and otherwise
impossibilities of charting black film
genealogies and in through archival
voids
and of course
scholars of black film history have long
incorporated speculative strategies in
their work to address partial archives
non-exam films and african-american
moviegoing experiences
for example in her study of black film
culture in chicago during the silent era
jacqueline stewart uses the novels of
louis eye and native son to engage
african-american spectatorial
experiences
according to stewart the descriptions of
black spectatorship in morrison and rice
novels open up facets of the movie going
experience that tend to be overlooked by
academic film criticism and offer
imaginative mediations about the realms
in which the academic study of
spectatorship tends to become fragmented
between
the analysis of ethnographic or
historical facts and psychoanalytic
theoretical speculation
as well
miriam petty extends stewart's
speculative interventions in her study
of black children's movie going
experiences in the 1930s turning to
first-person accounts via autobiography
and memoir when faced with a dearth of
pertinent primary source materials
and most specific to my reading of
knowledge allison nadia field examined
both non-extant black films prior to
1915 and more contemporary black films
that fabricate what she calls a
speculative archive of black film
history
these latter examples discussed by field
include the works produced by black
women film directors like sheryl donier
whose feature the watermelon woman
included the fictional actress faye
richards archive to highlight the
absence of black lesbians in 1930s
hollywood as well as julie dash's short
film illusions from 1982 which you can
also stream on hbo max just saw that
today
dramatizes the invisible labor of
african americans off-screen as
executives and talent during the studio
era in 1942.
field argues that both dunye and dash's
films model speculative approaches to
archival work through manufacturing
historical images and ephemera that get
at a set of concerns that are hidden in
and by history
as field explains both illusions and the
watermelon woman constructively offer
black film scholars a way to take on
archival absences the limits of evidence
the stakes of visuality and the
interpretive possibilities of symbolic
substitutes
in her own cinematic fabulation
knowledge's play and peritects invite
similar considerations about the
cultural practices productions and
politics of film historical
re-imagination and its bearing on black
women's media histories
with by the way meet bear stark
particularly the digital paratexts
knowledge attempts in hartman's terms to
tell an impossible story about the
circumstances and contributions of black
women in american cinema and to amplify
the impossibility of its telling through
an experimental and fragmented archive
dedicated to the fictional film star
now
this play is a transmedia production as
i've stated that includes websites the
finding they're finding very stark and
rediscovering very stark
these digital archives are fictions of
film history that replicate familiar
lost and found archival narrative
shaping preservation practices and
popular reception of black film history
which jacqueline stewart goes through
in depth in her study of the tyler texas
black film collection
now with not a display the media
paratexts include non-linear visual
materials and recollective histories
that resemble the objects and data as
well as the authoritative form and
artifice of many archives special
collections and digital humanities
initiatives
intended to be a storytelling tool
knowledge's paratexts are integral to
interpreting the play and specifically
bears narrative through the appeal and
limits
of factual evidence
simultaneously illuminating
and aestheticizing bear's story these
paratexts
paradoxically materialize the emptiness
of archives and that's to borrow from
catherine grew
as well as the cultural histories
documenting major and minor black
figures in american cinema in other
words the digital repository does not
solve issues of black actresses mute
archival presence but instead it makes
archival silences even louder
not a dissected archive exists on two
web domains
www.meetvarioustart.com and
www.findingbearstark.com
now currently
only the former domain
which is the website titled
rediscovering vera stark on the screen
here is still accessible and is
maintained by the character herb
forester who is on social media but
still currently will not accept my
friend request despite my many attempts
perhaps because he's not real i don't
know
but all jokes aside the loss of the
latter site underscores um how archives
even digital ones are not fathomless and
timeless places in which nothing goes
away especially if you do not renew the
internet domain name
the artifacts presented in the digital
archive are distinctly fragmented and
the remaining collection of images
ephemera narratives and histories work
against chronology and wholeness through
disjointed snapshots of vera's life and
career
assuming biographical data the home page
of rediscovering vera stark and
hopefully you can see this on your
screen describes the actress in
declarative speculative and hierographic
prose
bear stark the actress the singer the
lover the civil rights activist the maid
the housewife the teacher the femme
fatale the comic the tragedy the
murderer the murdered
the missing the performer the legend
she wore cascade of faces it says
with its repetitive
perhaps
the site is designed as a possibility
an imaginable way to celebrate the life
of one of the greatest actresses being
stark while also functioning as a beacon
that represents the hope that vera stark
is still out there alive and well and
willing to tell her story
the page requests that any viewers or
stark herself contact forrester at his
listed um
email address should they stumble onto
the site in fact rediscovering vera
stark reconciles a task of the task of
archiving as a search party where film
traces fragments and black subjects can
be retrieved if lost and or found
the website like all selective
incomplete and growing archives is a
contrived collection and a collective
enterprise
now i want to attend to these
peritectical contents a bit more closely
first the home page which includes a
short documentary a leading lady in a
maid's uniform a closer look at the
belle of new orleans was created and
narrated by forrester and it examines
vera's first film and her most famous
role
the documentary is in alexandria juha
juha's terms a productive fake
reminiscent of dunya's the watermelon
woman film which imitates the
documentary reform to make many related
claims about history that history is
untrue that true history is
irretrievable and fake histories can be
real
now a leading lady includes footage from
the bell of new orleans that airs during
the play as well as distinguished
talking heads discussing vera and the
film including the late director and
writer peter bogdanovich academy
award-winning cinematographer stuart
dreiberg and film scholar and professor
mia mask now let's take a look really
just a short clip from this nine-minute
excerpt
the bell of wars a film in which in its
inception nearly bankrupted semester
pictures overcame its rocky beginnings
to catapult the studio and its starbucks
to immortal train
it's essentially a picture of
silence but was the film an artful
masterpiece or a lucky confluence of
lesser talents
three artists are widely credited with
its success director maximilian von
oster
who's sort of almost
by desire
not quite in the mainstream
[Music]
a leading lady in a maid's uniform
in the early days of american cinema
black actors weren't even cast in films
you'd often have white actors in black
face and so a film like birth of a
nation comes to mind or even some of the
early versions of uncle tom's cabin it
was no accident that the ball of new
orleans was produced on the cusp of the
implementation of the haze production
code which enforced certain traditional
moral standards on the movies such as
banning extramarital sex and
miscegenation the mixing of the races on
screen
but my blood is impure
that it carries a drop of shame and
misery
from an octa room this is here the whole
idea of miscegenation and
the fact that uh
the leading character had a black blood
uh that was not something that code
dealt with afterwards the fact that
the black and white characters mingle
many scholars point to this film as the
straw that broke the camel's back and
got the code put into place
[Music]
[Music]
feel there are a lot of issues involved
in lighting black and white characters
in the same scene
darvin's like
maybe because he was
brazilian by birth the fact he came from
a liberal background
now it never seemed to him as conflict
the death of new orleans
but out of the pyrrhic fire emerged vera
stark one of the brightest
african-american stars of the 20th
century she really went away along with
actresses like echo waters or daddy
mcdaniel nina
louise beavers so being that kind of
trailblazer it opened the doors for
those actresses who came after her
through the 1950s and 60s she was an
ardent civil rights activist frequently
participating in marches and using her
stardom to pressure the zeitgeist
towards integration at one point she's
staying at one of the very fancy hotels
in california and tries to use the
swimming pool and unfortunately created
such a stir among the other white
patrons staying at the hotel the workers
had to clean the pool and refill it as a
victim himself of discrimination in
pre-war europe director van ostern
claimed to understand the plight of
african americans and jim crow parish
[Music]
style max was very sort of didactic go
over there and stand
stand there
but the monster was different with vera
he would go over
so in this absolutely insane
historically insane um but yet
convincing parody bear is a cipher who
shape-shifts through media through the
media displayed interview with
recollection and scholarly framing and
reframing
this website also includes navigation
links that are dedicated to different
aspects of vera's life and her career
we've got
a detailed filmography
um we've also got
which includes 57 films from 1933 to
1966 she's sometimes credited and
uncredited
there is a link to varus autobiography
it rained on my parade that contains
excerpts of two disjointed passages that
connects two characters in the play
there's links to vera in vegas which
includes
ephemera from her two-week performance
in feliz um
at the hotel tropicana in las vegas
which is very reminiscent of josephine
baker's career terms and the reviews
program features information about the
production and an image of showgirls
including vera dancing on stage
the photo of course doesn't tell us
which one is there exactly and elsewhere
it is explained that barrett
inexplicably stripped naked during her
final performance and was arrested for
public indecency
this site also includes an image gallery
including a cover of a danish magazine
featuring an image of a black woman
which we're to assume is vera um a photo
of a cast um the cast of loomis and
larry in which vera starred again very
unclear if she's even in the picture
and a photo of vera's star on the
hollywood walk of fame
now these ephemeral and incoherent
artifacts give substance to varus
phantom form reminding us of both the
immaterial histories of harris and other
lesser-known black actresses and often
the material randomness of archival
collections in fact the digital
hodgepodge undergirds the materials
veracity and import it's the fact that
it is so random that makes everything so
important
demonstrating how sparse stochastic and
significant archives of black film
figures are in general
and finally
the link that underscores the play's
animating question what happened to vera
chronicles the mystery and legend of
vera following her 1973 disappearance
and in questioning the very truth of
bear's existence the web page's citation
of film scholar me amassed his quote
from the documentary both a vows and
disavows the peritectual artifice now
let mass just say it ourselves i think
what's more interesting than the truth
is that the question exists in the first
place right that we don't know what
happened to vera
what an odd thing but nonetheless she
still says what's more interesting than
the truth is the question exists in the
first place that we don't know what
happened to vera
now with this quizzical paradox not a
disspeculative archive resists the
impulse to recover and reconstitute
black film history even as it mimics and
utilize the tools the institutions the
forms and the technologies history
making in its online repository
instead rediscovering vera stark is
meant to be a proposition of what could
have been but never was or what the
play's character herb laments at the
colloquium as theories rumors conjecture
as a peritextual appendage a problem set
whereupon
excuse me wearing a phantom limb of the
plays phantom cinema is layered atop
real and imagined film histories
rediscovering vera stark is a counter
history a shadow archive addressing
erasures of our from our collective
imagination
about absences that are nonetheless
present and real
and to point to that reality knowledge
tells of how many theatergoers did not
recognize that vera was even fabricated
even if they had felt acquainted with
the idea of her
as she recalls that the fictional herb
forester was contacted by the new york
film academy to lecture on the actress's
life
which is just insane
because we visited that many black films
got like you have to go to a fictional
person i hope they didn't do it during
black history month but nonetheless i
digress
it was to her music um now this
individual institutional confusion is
always already racialized and informed
by generic and academic ignorance and
still rediscovering their stark's
speculative digital archive produces and
preserves a counter-imaginary a
fantastic possibility filled with
spectral sources and subjects produced
within and against film history
and in fact as a composite of many
actresses there is a stand in and body
double for black women's acting labor in
hollywood and yes we're almost done stay
with me
beyond teresa harris various cinematic
doppelgangers include unsung talent such
as nina maybe kenny mildred washington
and butterfly mcqueen
in his film critic manola darkest writes
vera also represents the other women in
women's pictures the black cooks nurses
and maids made to breaking out of the
margins if only a little joked with mae
west fretted with claudette colbert and
stood by white woman after white woman
vera's fabricated life career and legacy
are multi-dimensional and necessitate an
analysis of the mythos of her star image
codifying richard dyer's claim that star
images have histories
knowledge documents pharah's legacy and
her intermedia and transmedia paratext
echoing creative productions that
mediate black women's
into and in film history such as cheryl
daniel and zoe leonard's filmmaking
photographic fabrication of faye
richards a fictive black lesbian actress
who starred in classic hollywood and
race films
in collaborating and constructing their
own phantom cinema via a diegetic
documentary and the extra diegetic faye
richards photo archive book
leonard explains that quote
faye richards is fictional but her life
is historically possible fragments of
richard's story was taken from the lives
of george the arsenal butterfly mcqueen
jessica baker and many others favorite
truth is a star this work started out as
material for cheryl's film the
watermelon woman but the project became
an artwork unto itself
i think partly because the project got
so big but also because the photographs
had have their own kind of logic and
completeness independent from the film
cheryl ended up only using the
photographs briefly in the film but it
becomes clear to me that they
constituted something on their own
similarly
not ages play in media peritects connect
to the theatrical production but also
constitute something on their own about
black actresses again a whole and a
whole
knowledge like huey copeland describes
of daniel and leonard's efforts attempts
to ethically fabulate a history to get
at some reality that is otherwise
occluded a reality that opens up
opens up something else and gets us to a
different set of possibilities that we
wouldn't have come upon if we were just
hemmed in by what was available to us
that's kind of a really key point
i'm just not interested in what we just
have um i'm interested in what we can
imagine
knowledge gives us vera a person who as
leonard explains about her fabricated
actress faye a person who could have
lived though even if she had we probably
wouldn't have known about her
not just vera makes black women's
invisibility visible her digital and
media archive is a found object of lost
media histories
and this makes sense because another
media work knowledge created was a video
titled lost and found a documentary set
to be produced by the place character
carmen levy green
and it contained speculative tragic and
celebratory impulses to capture the
legacy of vera and these impulses are
not just examples of knowledge's
creative fiction but are endemic in
popular historic interventions about
marginalized black actresses
evidenced most
relevantly in turner classic movies
theresa harris a forgotten overlooked
star about vera's real life inspiration
now this three minute video includes
footage of harris from a range of films
along with the epigraph you may have
seen her face but you but don't know her
name i'm just gonna play for like two
seconds
[Music]
sorry
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so as you saw um it's not a very long
video it's only three minutes um the
video is found online is an overt and on
to not itch but this acknowledgement
only serves to overlay how differently
tcm and the playwright render the
influence and impact of their respective
lost and found or forgotten overlooked
actress actress
in crafting a story about harris tcm was
in a similar bind as knottage with not
much to go on about harris besides her
film roles which are used as visuals
throughout the video
tcm straightforward video however
demonstrates a historical resignation
unlike nottage's reimagination to the
fact that harris was statically framed
within the racialized moving images and
racial scripts of hollywood
tcn's brand of film history which
i now feel responsible for much like the
scholarship on black actresses finds its
forgotten overlooked star through her
filmography
the fixed moving images that showed
talent but no parts for harris despite
her scene stealing and studio pictures
and star-turning abilities and race
films
in contrast
nottage moves harris to a new stage
where she can inhabit a familiar yet
different role as vera stark
and just as harris could not shake the
typecast role that dominated her career
bera struggles to move past her career
defining role in the bell of new orleans
in the play's archival footage from the
brad donovan show bear tries to talk
about something other than her role as
tilly the maid to which the show's host
questions if she's trying to change the
subject you can see it on screen
vera responds
it's been the subject of my life for the
last 40 years
of course i'm trying to change the
subject
like so many actors who were criticized
for their on-screen roles vera inherits
his image and knowledge's imagination
reminds us that black actresses
ambitions and histories are more than
their on-screen images even if those
visages are all we are left to
contemplate
in these instances historicizing and
recreating their careers for critical
and creative purposes requires changing
the subject in more ways than one
and the play does exactly that it
changes the subject of black actresses
in and what could too easily be
concluded as a recuperative and
reparative act of historical
reimagination
but i want to caution against reading
knowledge's phantom cinema in romantic
terms even as it advances heartening
black feminist and film histographic
methods of finding black women where
there was none but also where they
always were
phantom cinemas are meant to be
disquieting
and not a just stage play is a ghost
story and her digital media paratexts
are an archival apparition that
collectively trouble our vision of film
history more than it clarifies it
in the end we are not really closer to
harris's true film history but we are in
vera's shadow haunted by harris's actual
absence from it and our popular memory
by the way me vera stark and other black
feminist cinematic imaginaries take
shape in but do not actually fill the
lacuna by remaking film history
and it is this creative and creation
process that relies on the inability and
refusal to tell a whole story of
cinema's past
necessitating both historically grounded
and experimental approaches to material
and immaterial black film archives
in tandem these inventive and
resourceful efforts reinforce the
histographic method suggested by the
plays character herb forster on his
website rediscovering vera stark
and questioning both what happened to
vera and if we are asking the wrong
questions in general about the truth
behind her disappearance
forrester writes
perhaps we can sift some truth out of
the rumor mills detritus
what a weird sentence
yet
the incomplete fragmented material and
immaterial debris
of unverified and creative histories are
by the way
rife with use and value facts and
fantasies about black women's cinematic
past
changing the subject of dominant film
history to be about black women requires
and inspires historians playwrights
scholars and audiences to excavate
experiment innovate and reimagine their
lives cinema and archives in stark new
ways
thank you
i will be taking questions and i can
imagine you're giving me this amount of
tarajit hints and energy in response
um i'll i'll stop looping this because
it'll just keep going because she's
really into it
perfect
let me stop sharing
i really love ending on the on that
gif you know if we were in person that's
exactly what it what the room would have
looked like so
really happy to end on that note um
thank you so much for that uh
fascinating talk professor
uh it's definitely got me thinking about
a lot of stuff but i want to
sort of extend the microphone to
students
and attendees if anybody has any
questions
go ahead amber
hi samantha thank you so much for your
wonderful talk i have a question
actually about your research
and how you move
from what i understand that you were
researching on sports and blackness and
how you move or why did you decide to
move to cinema
women and blackness so it's a great
question i mean i think it's
kind of important to to reframe that so
my training is in cinema and media
studies so i'm i'm not a sports studies
scholar i am a person who is interested
in
in media um and
um sports films is very um under
theorized um and particularly i'm
interested in um and blackness
so
that's that's the the larger umbrella
frame of all of my work and so it
manifests in in sports films um
in one way and then as i was
reapproaching and granted i i have to
now because i talk about sports all the
time and so a healthy ambivalence has
has created a problem but um but now
that has sort of shifted because i'm
trying to think about sort of questions
that animated
interestingly enough
a chapter in the sports film book um
about black women sports films and their
bodies started off with
an engagement with michelle wallace's
idea of a black hole i thought this is
really something she's like there are no
sports films etc like there's no his
like you know we've got to read the gaps
and i was like that could describe
really a lot of things um because that's
what it's not even meant to be
describing these films um and so it's
it's a fun and
now
great connection i get to make which is
if you look at that chapter you use
that's the opening really the opening
idea it becomes the little liberal book
title of this work that is much more
invested in questions of black women's
media history a question of archive
like many folks taking a speculative
turn
and and also trying to engage with
disrupting the idea of having to
recreate chronologies
to get at genealogies and i think that's
that's something that this work is
trying to do
so thank you
yeah thank you
also like you know you all are
interested in a lot of things your
dictation is one thing but you get tired
of that you have a lot of things you
want to talk about
um
[Music]
hi thank you for being here and for that
lovely talk really appreciate it
um
my question is actually about how you
create boundaries in the process of like
viewing some of this work that can
possibly be
traumatizing or cause distress within
you as a person it's something that i
think
in dealing with really complex histories
and film history being so inherently
racist like how do you take care of
yourself essentially because i think we
don't talk about that enough in academia
that's such a really good question i
will say i also going to gravitate to
things that i like
but despite the fact that i also don't
really care for this play i don't i did
not find it to be that enjoyable to
watch um
but i gravitate to things that i also
find much more interesting um in fact
the sports film stuff taught me
because all of those are just like
stories of racism like they become
overcome like you scored the winning
basket and like racism is solved but
like you were first like you know beat
down by oppression um
so
um which is to i really try to pick
objects that i am
that bring me joy and to some degree i
really like talking about these
these paratex i sort of came across
i saw this play on a date
and i was like it was okay you know it's
different what it was but it wasn't all
that i mean i didn't marry that man so
it's fine um but like so
i saw the play i was like it was okay
but then i was i was like i really want
i started writing about something else i
wrote about leslie harris's um attempt
to fund her second film via kickstarter
and it have failed
and i was like there's something here
about all of these black women ideas
that i'm just like trying to navigate
and then when i came back to this i said
oh there's an entire website full of
full of
fake histories i i am so invested here
so
that's a so it's it's not answering
partially your question which is that i
kind of just pick things that i find
really really joyful um
um but also i
i think in reading all the other stuff
that i find less like
all of these great black feminists so
many of them have passed away from the
academy like they try to kill you um so
also trying to honor that like all of
this great knowledge exists like all of
like we have to write these stories um
and so i am in a very very very good
group of people who are very edifying to
the work that i do
um and
i also
it is my month i can't think about them
i just don't like dealing white nonsense
when i don't have to
and i um
and oh i do i now have i basically can't
watch any dramas
i live a light comedy life
thank you i have an element like i
basically cannot engage with
like i get that i think you may have
seen it but like this is my face because
you know
zoom um and i work at an institution so
like i'm happy to be here i don't know
i'm fine um but at the end of the day i
i basically have to overly temper in in
enjoy
um to
to function as a human in this world
which means that i just wish you all
love and and enjoy and good comedy and
seven seasons in a movie
i love i wish that was a hard function
don't worry i could make you get out of
this world it's great
i love it
this is awesome yeah i was looking for
the heart reaction too
um
and
i've learned this year to embrace uh
like trashy reality tv which i've never
been super into before and i feel like
that's been a form of like
self-care of sorts or like just trying
to rebalance um
yeah the the hard work that can be that
can take a lot of emotional toll
um
with something that's like
light and that i'm not super invested in
yeah i also i mean because it's
not to keep answering the same that same
question so sorry if and but
yeah um
like i will we'll do this work it
happens less in my work because i take
my work to
certain places it happens really mostly
and maybe you all see this as as
educated when you're doing teaching i'm
teaching intro to african-american
cinema it's like it's the history of
racism and also like resistance but
it's difficult like you just kind of
keep going through you're like okay oh
we get to the groundbreaking film called
do the right thing you know we get to
the
reason of the sun it's just i'm like
that really isn't a happy story like but
reign did a thing but it is not that
kind of you know it's we go it's just
like the 20s the 30s we're just talking
about all the stuff that's happening in
the world so it's really
telling them to to to feel their
feelings but also to like
laugh like just really if something is
funny that is absolutely just
to to to fill it with yeah with laughter
but i find teaching to be the most
because you got to show the stuff but
it's really really can be really really
harmful
um
one sense of self
hi
emily
thank you
dr shepherd thank you so much for
joining us and sharing your work with us
um my question is just if you can share
a little bit about
what future work you're thinking of or
already working on um and whether it
continues along some of these same lines
or themes
perfect well yeah no this is so this is
part of a book and this is technically
part of the introduction i know it's
just it became so it's like a huge ass
introduction that is
trying to explain phantom cinemas
through this example and then it goes in
nine different or maybe six chapter
directions um so like i said i'm
interested in doing uh um
a history of women of them
um of reimagining women's media
histories by re-engaging black women's
media histories but
but not in a chronology like there will
be no and this person came first and
this person came for in the next um but
i'm while still attending to like peer
review and needing a chapter that kind
of does the work of in search of our you
know
of our mother cinemas kind of situation
um so that's just like a this is a big
book project this is part of the academy
this is the project that i pitched for
them
um um so i'll have to finish that
sometime
um and i plan on it
technically i will finish
parts of it are written like this like
part of the intro and the part on leslie
harris and the whole section on um
um speculative archives are all digital
so what do we do with the kickstarters
and the indiagogos and like where they
have like fully conceptualized idea what
do we do with the spec script what do we
do with all of these i guess the idea
that like oh there are no black women
media we've got i was like we have been
like creating stuff it's just like it's
not out there but it's out there it has
been it's been narrativized and
different smaller and imagined in a
range of ways so i want to account for
that
i think professor shepard's screen is
for us
okay
let's give her a moment um
[Music]
oh you're back
i'm back your screen was frozen for a
bit so we missed like the last maybe
don't worry i think you fumbled a little
bit so we'll just drop that one off
somewhere but it's a it's got a few
different chapters it's
a piece on collections and
collectivities so thinking about
the
formidability of black women film and
video makers which is the book which
everybody if you're going to teach black
women filmmakers you have that book it's
a huge collection um and things like the
collectivities of like the new negros
film society that exists like what are
the connections between these and
technically despite my general
ambivalence about sports i am
contractually obligated unfortunately to
write a book on called the basketball
film a cultural and trans media history
which was due last year
so i'm working on that
soon
due soon
um the version of this talk will be in
feminist media histories
um and
yeah
yeah
and i i just i just
yeah
yeah i'm just doing you know how you all
just do like little random things like a
chapter on documentary films and
so how you got roped into that
it's just you get after a while you
first think will i have opportunities
and you say i don't want any more
opportunities make me like let's let's
stop
because i'm booked to 2023 and
the future is
the future is bleak um in terms of
i just want to not
i don't know if it is still recording i
do want to work
but i also want a break
so so i'm working on two books a book on
basketball and this women's media
histories book
and teaching and trying to figure out
all the fun things that we want our life
and legacy to be and develop new courses
and
um
and be in conversation and support
younger scholars which is a great way
for me to right now do a little um plug
for jcms if any of you all are ever
interested in publishing in the journal
cinema media studies we have a great
publishing initiative so please feel
free to also reach out to me and check
out the website at www.put it in google
there's enough key terms you got it
uh and you said your own sabbatical so i
see you have a very relaxing sabbatical
planned yes
i mean
i'm going to
i'm going to write one of those books
hopefully
is the basketball book focusing on women
on black women in basketball
specifically or you know just the
basketball film as a film and media as a
genre so the hiss the relationship
between the history of the sport and the
media around the sport
so
i mean honestly that sounds really cool
it's it
yes i mean yeah it'll be it'll be
something it'll it's gonna come together
i
it seems like a good idea a couple years
ago
and now here i am
um so but it'll be fun because there's a
great series part of a screening and
sports series and there's a book on the
boxing film and a book on the baseball
films and it does a really great job of
building out the different changes that
happen in terms of technologies culture
and the sport itself and how that shifts
our understanding of
the media that's created but also our
understanding of the sport itself
and as a person who didn't even make jv
basketball i feel well suited to
get there and do that
um okay we have time for a couple or
maybe even a few more questions
as folks are kind of maybe thinking
about things i i really feel like the
talk was fascinating and touched upon
like so many different disciplines and
so many different
subfields um and i wanna hear you talk
more about all of them but specifically
i wanna ask you about like the archive
um and sort of how
what your conception of the archive is
kind of the relationship of this piece
to the archive like
you know um i think the archive itself
can be a place that is sort of
determined by dominant culture in this
case probably white culture and white
american history and so
how are you kind of
conceiving of the archive
that's a really great question i mean
part of this has been um
trying to engage with what i even mean
by the term so like you know you go back
and you read your
archive fever and you also read your
dust by you know
carol stephen and i was actually reading
this different book by jenny sharp
called immaterial archives
about african diaspora poetics which i
felt was the most that i
that i really felt was what i was trying
to get at um which is
of course it's for some people it is a
physical space it's a special collection
that has particular policies but i think
in reading steedman and then also
reading sharp um is
is really trying to think about the way
in which um
the way in which it's really this sort
of contrived collective space
and the things themselves are also
highly constructed for us as both
meaningful and also as as material
which is why i really was interested in
the idea of fabricating digital material
proof especially in the digital age of
needing this kind of evidence it's not
enough just to say she existed you can
literally go and see images that are
supposed to relate to her and that we
could print out or save the web page and
see this you can watch the the video
essay which is now its own form of you
know sort of documentary um proof
um
and so for me
thinking about the archive particularly
when it comes to black film figures is
like is to play with the critique that i
think
was best done and
cheryl dunny is the watermelon woman
when they go visit the [ __ ] archive and
they're like where is black lesbians and
she's like oh well we have some photos
over here in a box on the side like it's
where we see these these histories are
so
not memorialized
so if i take that as the conceit not
saying that i don't think that archival
practices are key i'm in love with
jacqueline stewart's work i'm in love
with miriam petty's work i'm in love
with alice nadia phil's work i'm in love
with a lot of the um folks coming up who
are doing really strong archival work
like
oh my god haley what is your last name
right now it's not coming to me but um
um who's at iowa people who are going
and and doing all this archival work i
am with you in spirit part-time um
just
can't be inside a building for too long
um and i say that because i think that
there's so much important but if i am
just concerned by what exists
for a people who were not meant to exist
like not meant to really be manifested
then i think i it's it's
it's not the work of
of black feminist practice which is
about
producing the forms of power that will
bring you freedom so that means
sometimes also fabricating those things
fabricating material histories what if i
take the assumption that she was there
what if i say vera is harris but not
obviously not harris
the things we know about harris can be
summed in um what we find really in the
black press
about her talking about her relationship
to an industry that we already
understand to be racist and to be sexist
so is that the most meaningful part of
her when we don't mind getting 95
different versions of what was marilyn
monroe's inner thought of what is she
having a biscuit like i want to just
imagine she didn't eat biscuits
right like what if we just took it as
the i find that to be useful um so our
archive itself is also something that we
that we must we must make and therefore
it highlights all these issues that we
have of the archives and then when it
gets to digital humanities issues
initiatives which it's all about we must
digitize we must digitize we must
preserve um what does it mean to
preserve a reimagination um what does it
mean to me to hold on to this i finally
checked the domain name for this website
is good for five more years
but nonetheless i was you know copy
paste save save save let me create these
spring grabs because lord knows when
this book will be done um but because
it'll it can be gone but this existed
this entire fabrication existed so vera
stark the actress the legend the
comedienne the murder the murderous was
real in a way and i think that's really
important when we think about digital
archives more so than physical space
archives um and i think it's important
we think about immaterial archive which
is that she materializes a kind of
immateriality like i can print this out
but i'm never gonna hold that paper
because it's not real anyways
um so what does that mean um about our
understanding of the past which is that
like it's gone baby it's
here but it's gone like
but it's also present so i'm i'm really
interested in the play between those
things and
um
yeah but i'm definitely interested in
fabulation and all the things that
we can take from heart men while also
realizing that hartman has a very
different
ethical and historical project at stake
very different claims we're making but
we're but we're all invested in the work
that hartman is inspired by which is
bambara in giddings and all the people
who have gone back and said where do we
exist
where did we
exist and how do we amplify that
existence
that's very powerful thank you
um we've got time for one more question
or amusing a comment
yes these are shoes
little shoes on yes
that's what we were all wondering that's
over everything i tell people
please
give me a look
um
or any general question or any
which is no pressure
for the fact that you're even here
after hours is nice enough
well we really appreciate you uh giving
us some of your time and sharing uh you
know the spoiler alert of the book to
come
um
definitely going to be waiting for that
so no pressure though no pressure all
right you keep
living got it we're it's coming along
piece by piece it'll slowly
exist in the world
um
yeah but all right well if there aren't
any more questions then join me in a
virtual thank you to professor shepard
thank you thank you all thank you for
attending thank you
for your questions and i hope everyone
is is finding sustained
um and at the very least sufficient joy
during these very very very difficult
times and
that your work is hopefully very
meaningful to you
that you're that you're moving along and
that we we wait for it eagerly
so thank you
thank you so much
thank you
of course bye